- You grew up coming to Universal Studios
and now you work at Universal Studios.
That's kind of trippy.
- It's such a trip.
I grew up in L.A. and as a kid
we'd come and ride the tram
and it was just magic.
It was just oh my god, one day
maybe I'll get to make movies
or make TV and now every
day about 100 times a day
the tram goes right by my trailer
and goes "Starring America Ferrera!"
- That's amazing!
(audience applauds)
- It's sort of like the
first time in the day
I'm welling up and remembering being a kid
and by the 100th time in the day I'm like,
"Oh my god, I don't wanna
hear my name anymore."
- It's really cool and a novelty at first.
Then you're like, "Cool,
it's still happening."